To defeat the bugs, we
must catch the bugs.
We must different on
all fronts to ensure
they're caught early and often.
Compile time checks
help, but there's also
a whole set of runtime
checks we can also use.
That's where
StrictMode comes in,
offering a set of
runtime checks you
can add to your debug builds
to catch potential issues
before they hit your users.
I'm Ian Lake, and I'll
walk you through two
of my favorite
StrictMode features
that go beyond
performance checks
and help you build better apps.
So if link checks are the
Android-specific compile time
problems you can tell
you about, StrictMode
is the runtime equivalent,
pointing out issues
that we can detect at runtime
so you can fix them early.
Much of StrictMode is
performance-focused.
The other Ian does
a great job talking
about those features
in his video,
as well as the
basics of StrictMode.
But I'm not here to rehash that.
Instead, let's talk
about the cool new stuff,
like VM policy's
detectFileUriExposure.
If you're sharing
content with other apps,
you do not want to
be using file URIs.
They require
storage permissions,
and they can't
cross between users,
and-- well, just watch my
dev byte on sharing content.
The StrictMode check
just makes sure
that those file URIs don't
make it out to other apps.
Like all StrictMode,
you can have
it log the issue with penaltyLog
or kill your app completely
with penaltyDeath.
Build better apps or death.
Should be an easy choice, right?
Now, new to Android
6.0 Marshmallow
is detectCleartextNetwork.
As you might expect
from the name,
this detects unencrypted network
traffic over IPv4 or IPv6,
whether using TCP or UDP.
The thing about mobile
devices out in the wild
is that you can't
really guarantee
that they'll actually be
connected to trustworthy access
points.
Risking the security
of your user's data
or the communication
to your server
is the last privacy
nightmare you want
to deal with on launch day.
So detect it early and
encrypt your network traffic.
One thing to keep in mind,
you may find false positives
when using STARTTLS
protocols or HTTP proxies.
Something to be aware of is
StrictMode starts killing it
when you're, in
fact, doing it right.
Now, with your app
creating extra logging
and being killed and
all that, you probably
want to keep in mind that
StrictMode should only
be enabled for debug builds.
The easiest way to do that is
by wrapping your StrictMode
calls in a buildConfig debug
check, which is automatically
set to false on release builds.
There's a lot more to
explore with StrictMode.
But detecting file URIs and
cleartext network traffic
can be extremely useful
in finding issues
before they are
experienced by your users,
giving you that
extra peace of mind
that you're building
better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]